das ist einfach alles sind zwei euro
fünfzig ungefährlich wäre uns wirklich
aufgeschmissen
wo soll man es mehr kriege jetzt um die
uhrzeit mit meinen 52 ich kann euch auch
gerne als beweis man vielleicht dem
screenshot einen von meinem konto ich
kann es halt nicht wirklich überziehen
hey leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video und schönen guten
morgen aus berlin der ich bin gerade in
berlin und habe mir echt schöne aussicht
aber wegen das erste mal frühstücken
weil ich hab hunger und danach geht's
los
soweit fertig mit frühstück war echt
cool frühstück
ihr habt ihr so was schon mal gesehen
ich bin hier oben im zimmer und das
fenster wird einfach geputzt von außen
auf 150 meter höhe 100 meter höhe ist
glaube ich der ist hier in diesen dingen
drin und putz das von herzen so weit
für mich geht es jetzt los ich muss
jetzt hier auschecken wirklich schönes
kleines zimmer gewesen mit einem schönen
ausblick
[Musik]
und zwar habe ich so ein
vorstellungsgespräch oder so schwer zu
sagen was das genau ist will seine
fernsehserie
ich weiß nicht ich wollten keinen bock
machen nehmen euch einfach mal mit mal
gucken was passiert ich mir vielleicht
noch so alles challenge überlegt von mir
gab es ja letztens diese videos die
ersten werbung die mir angezeigt werden
auf instagram und der youtuber ich weiß
es schon mal gemacht muss ich kaufen
ich habe mir überlegt in berlin wird
sich das auch anbieten dass du réel zu
machen halt in dem man durch die straßen
geht und hier gibt es überall so große
werbeplakate und einfach sowas macht zu
machen keine ahnung vielleicht mal ganz
lustig war aber mal sehen was der tag so
bringt
und ja ich würde sagen netz so leute
elektrisch wahrscheinlich es ist immer
noch freitag also gestern bin ich
morgens aufgestanden habe den bock
angefangen nein wir haben schon samstag
und das ist einiges passiert ich bin
zwar immer noch in berlin allerdings nur
noch für ungefähr drei stunden oder so
wenn ihr bei der guten freund der auch
daher kommen wo ich eigentlich herkommt
und so und das ist einiges passiert was
eigentlich ganz lustig es nicht
unbedingt lustig aber ich sehe es lustig
an weil als auch ein bisschen dumm ist
von mir jetzt ich mal kurz die story und
zwar reise ich eigentlich eher ungern
nicht viel geld dabei als ich habe immer
meine karte dabei und wenn sich gelb
rote karte bei hitzacker und ich bin
jemand ich passe mal sehr gut auf mein
geld auf also immer wenn ich irgendwie
neues geld bekommen oder so jeden durch
erst mal so viel wie möglich davon zur
seite an dass ich auch dann nicht dran
kann und auch youtuber müssen ab und zu
steuern zahlen das ist ja ganz klar
und ich musste jetzt irgendwie das
nebenan war das vorgestern ich habe es
erst gestern gesehen wie willst steuern
zahlen was hat natürlich einfach ein
gesund wird es noch vollkommen okay aber
das habe ich total vergessen das heißt
gestern war freitag
und ich kann erst montag meine bank dazu
bewegen mit geld mein festes geld wo ich
halt selber nicht sein kann
zugeben dass ich da halt wieder was mit
anfangen kann und habe jetzt einfach für
das gesamte wochenende hatte also ich
hatte glaube ich 80 euro dabei wohin
geflogen bin war und jetzt habe ich noch
dass das einfach alles sind 250
das heißt das wird hier in blogs sowie
den eigentlich geplant habe wo ich heute
durch die city und so ein bisschen nach
werbung aus aber halte weil ich es mir
nicht leisten kann
es ist auch noch wieder eine sehr
interessante situation informiert das
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich fliege es
welche doch so über köln muss dann mit
nach hause nehmen nach düsseldorf legt
werden da abgeholt und muss mit meinem
auto nach köln
und ich habe auch 80 kilometer sprit
also eigentlich locker bis nach köln
aber ich kann mir absolut nichts kaufen
- wochenende
und ja da nehme ich euch jetzt mal mit
ich schau mal was passiert und ich kann
euch auch gerne als beweis man
vielleicht seinem speed und von meinem
konto ich kann es halt nicht wirklich
überziehen ist einfach so ist mit meiner
bank nicht so verhandelt keine ahnung
habe ich mich auch nie wirklich drum
gekümmert und ja deswegen geht es gleich
zum flughafen und wir schauen mal was
der tag so bringt das später ist alles
irgendwie so teuer hier
[Musik]
und
soweit ich bin jetzt angekommen in
düsseldorf
und ich habe schon versucht geld
abzuheben bei dieser bank geht nicht die
muss allerdings von hier irgendwie
wegkommen weil mein auto nicht hier
steht und jetzt muss ich mich abholen
lassen kann ich mir noch 52
[Musik]
ich könnte ja mit 250 im bus fahren
wer zu wenig geld
so leute jetzt habe ich kurz mal zeit
ein kleines update zu geben weil ich
irgendwie das gefühl habe dass ich noch
gar nicht so richtig alles erklärt habe
ich würde jetzt gerade in düsseldorf
abgeholt am flughafen und ich konnte
nicht mit dem taxi fahren weil ein auto
hatte ich woanders geparkt einfach weil
es günstiger ist das jetzt hier
oh ja und ich weiß gerade nach köln ich
habe absolut nichts gegessen heute seit
ungefähr 14 uhr haben wir heute
irgendwie also einmal habe ich halte was
gegessen jetzt haben wir 21 und 40 und
das nächste problem ist wie man hier
sehen kann ich muss noch insgesamt 23
kilometer fahren
hab allerdings hier auch nur noch moment
54 kilometer lang das heißt ich bin bis
montag auf jeden fall nicht mobil das
nächste problem ist noch wer mehr als 20
ich hab noch 52 und spaß ist jetzt kein
fake oder so ich komme mir selber vor
wie im film
aber ich hab noch 20 minuten dann macht
er rede zu und ich kann ja nicht zu
einer tankstelle gehen oder zu einem
rewe to go oder so weil da ist es viel
teurer da kriege ich vielleicht für
meine zwei euro fünfzig ein brötchen und
wovon soll ich morgen leben also ich
weiß erst mal nach hause dann sehen wir
weiter
es ist natürlich auch lustig nehmen es
mit humor immer schon die nerven
behalten und das ist meine rettung hier
war noch zu fünft drin
von meinem letzten video aus dem
automaten
endlich bin ich zu hause eigentlich noch
immer zweieinhalb stunden ja sein sollen
aber ich hab's geschafft und das ding
jetzt ich auf so heftigen hunger ich
hoffe wir haben noch irgendwas was mir
schmeckt so leute kleine live test ich
kann nur kurz sagen ich habe etwas
gefunden und zwar haben wir hier noch
ein paar pfandflaschen das müssen ja
maximal zwei euro seien aber das hilft
mir in der situation auf jeden fall
schon mal weiter so kürzer gehört nicht
mehr geil eiswürfel da brauche ich mir
keine sorgen mehr machen und noch im
markt um ein witz ist es noch gut bitte
keine bessermacher daran ich finde ich
nicht so oft hier und deswegen weil so
aber ich bin froh bevor ich jetzt heute
kaum noch was vernünftiges kriege ich
wäre es ist heftig ich wäre es uns
wirklich aufgeschmissen wo soll man es
mehr kriege jetzt um die uhrzeit mit
meinen 250 vielleicht hat sich das ja
vermehrt ich vielleicht haben wir
miteinander
euro gemacht oder so also wir haben
jetzt mittlerweile schon kurz was für
mich weil das schlafen gehen ich habe
jetzt eben schnell gegessen und hatten
auch hier diesen diesen maracujasaft
gefunden weil wir auch nichts mehr zu
trinken ja etwas also ich kann das
natürlich aus dem geraden rekord in köln
das sehr kalt das schmeckt halt nicht
also ich zeige euch nochmals kommen wir
jetzt hier uns noch mal geld also dass
das ganze geld was ich halt noch hatte
ich habe heute eigentlich nichts mehr
ausgegeben
okay von vier reitern 1 euro 50 2 eur 42
gut 52 bisschen mehr wahrscheinlich
fragen sich jetzt auch viele jedoch
einfach von irgendwem geld wenn du jetzt
müssen runter hin geld hat natürlich
könnte ich das machen das ding ist ich
würde jetzt nicht von wem ich bin jemand
ich mag ich überhaupt nicht mehr geld zu
leihen
und ich habe überlegt ob ich ihn nur
irgendwo geld hab keine ahnung anwesen
wirklich die hände gebunden ich habe
auch paypal kein geld mehr wo ich
meistens mal so behalten die pizza
bestellen oder so abend wie schon gesagt
ich komme einfach essen und hat wieder
an geld und ich finde es
heftig einfach weil man damit gar nicht
rechnen ich weiter hätten wir jetzt kein
essen mehr gehabt hätte ich wirklich
entweder über das leihen müssen oder
halt fand vielleicht zusammen wir aber
so mein guter stehen nur noch relativ
viele aber ich finde es eigentlich ganz
interessant und ich habe schon gesagt
ich nehme zu tun trotzdem zeigt das eine
mal wieder wie gut man das eigentlich
hat man also ich geschlafen worden muss
ich noch überstehen und morgen gehen
aber irgendwie einkaufen und bisschen
hier mit meinem kleinen geld ich bin
gespannt auf den worten und taten später
auch deutschland also heute waren sehr
anstrengend wir sehen uns war so leute
guten morgen gerade wie du jetzt bin ich
gespannt auf dein tag heute spielt auf
jeden fall deutschland ich bin ja mehr
gefragt wenn ich freue mich riesig denn
normalerweise würde ich anderem heutigen
tag ganz zur tankstelle fahren und etwas
oder zum rewe to go etwas zu essen holen
unter der woche wurde ich mir natürlich
auch mal schon vorher war es was ich mir
dann morgen zwangen kann aber wir haben
einfach nichts mehr am auto abholen
können ich hoffe diese noch gut an alle
müssen die eigentlich also frühstück
jetzt erstmal dann werde ich aber
trotzdem einkaufen fahren um zu schauen
ob ich vielleicht irgendwas bekomme was
ich dann halt mittags und abends essen
kann
wobei ich die chance da wirklich sehr
sehr gering einschätze ich freue mich
einfach so dass heute wm ist und das ist
mir egal so ich habe jetzt erst mal 1 1
geballert um zu gucken ob das überhaupt
noch schmeckt so weit ich weiß zum rewe
to go also das ist eine rede an seiner
tankstelle und haben noch ein paar
flaschen drin
das ist nicht viel weil das sind
eigentlich nur glasflaschen aber wir
werden mal sehen ich denke ich kann man
sogar 450 oder ist nicht zur verfügung
so
mal sehen ich kann noch 29 km fahren wo
ich bin da und ich würde sagen also
sollte eigentlich im ersten wasser holen
das hätte aber 164 gekostet das war das
günstigste was an der tankstelle es war
zwar 0,75 viel zu viel
dann habe ich mir diese waffen geholt
für einen euro also 99 cent noch mehr
futter bringt soviel 165 2 eur 64
bezahlt und mehr war einfach nicht drin
ich muss jetzt schauen was ich damit
heute anfang wasser gibt es dann halt
heute auch wenn es nicht so lecker ist
aus dem kran lecker so leute einfach 1 0
für deutschland ich habe ja gesagt
eigentlich bedeutet und für mexiko 1 und
mexiko reicht deutschland ist echt nicht
so gut ich habe gesagt 31 das tut es nur
die maries jetzt gekommen und ich habe
zumindest jetzt hier schon mal wartet
wasser bekommen und was und ich glaube
um geld muss ich mir jetzt auch keine
gedanken mehr machen deswegen erstmal
bis hierhin also ich war von der iss an
den ganzen tag und heute bei ungefähr
mit dem pfandflaschen 354 ich habe jetzt
noch 90 cent übrig das was mit dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen das loch
nach oben da falls ja und ich bin ein
überlebenskünstler
wir schauen jetzt fußball zur insel
normalerweise für mich auch die weißen
papier mäßig aber ist nur das erste
spiel und dann stelle ich mir das video
online checks apples haltung ab wir
sehen uns morgen und übermorgen wieder
rein